[Music]
dare we
and that my friends is how a revolution
dies
if you're a fan of the hunger games then
you know that the four blockbuster films
dealt with some heavy dark and at more
than one time
heartbreaking subject matter so you'd
think that the set would be just as
serious
right well not exactly by all accounts
the hunger games set was known to be a
dynamic playful and cheerful place
despite the dark dystopian realities of
pan m
today we're bringing you the best behind
the scenes moments of this wickedly
talented set
including which tributes pulled off the
best pranks who gave josh hutcherson a
bad concussion and why jennifer lawrence
is
according to liam hemsworth somehow the
best and also the
worst actor to work with on set my smile
is so ingenuine
people are gonna think that i hate
actually despite being love interest on
screen jennifer lawrence and josh
hutcherson were nothing but
absolute pals off by all accounts fellow
actors producers and other personnel
could not help but mention how despite
their character's serious and dramatic
storylines
these two could not stop joking around
with each other
up until the camera started rolling
you'd think that the director and his
team
would be super annoyed with two kids
fooling around on set
but these two were anything but
unprofessional as soon as the director
yelled
tracking with the three-year difference
between the two
jennifer and josh clearly had a big
sister little brother vibe while filming
the hunger games movies
watch these behind-the-scenes outtakes
of the two chasing
and pushing each other between takes and
don't for a second think that these
feelings expressed by josh weren't
mutual
in this outtake jennifer is literally
pushing him around like a big sister
with a little brother
when you consider how close these two
were it's easy to understand why these
two had such an electric on-screen
chemistry
not to mention seeing these two stars
have fun on the job must have inspired
others on set to not take their job too
seriously
one of the most intense scenes of the
four movies is when joshua's character
starts to go into a manic in the
mockingjay
on-screen peta looks like he's inches
away from taking away katniss's life
but in real life apparently the scene
was extremely difficult to take without
one or the other
bursting into laughter
watch this hilarious outtake of jennifer
and josh pretending to be cats between
takes to cut the tension of an
otherwise dark and violent scene and
then maybe
we have a shot of being friends
according to sources the hunger games
set was a major prank war between actors
not surprisingly jennifer is probably
the one who started it all when she
accidentally gave
josh a minor concussion while training
for a combat scene on set
i kicked him in the head by accident
apparently the only fitting way josh
thought he could get even with his
co-star was to sneak glimmers body
double into jen's trailer
the dummy thing had me for a little bit
listen to these snippets
on how the prank went down he put a dead
dummy on my toilet holding toilet paper
and scared me
so when she opened up her bathroom to go
to the bathroom she saw a
rotting human being the prank scared jen
so much that there's a circulating rumor
that she even peed her pants
with how terrified she was sources tell
me that she actually peed her pants
i i didn't see it for fact this just
goes to show that you shouldn't mess
with either of these young actors
unless you're ready to be injured or
downright petrified
i just like to keep a set fun speaking
of pranks other actors took it upon
themselves to put the prank and jokes
queen jennifer
in her place actor jeffrey wright who
plays bt in mockingjay
famously gifted his young co-star a
beautiful tiffany box only to find it
full of live crickets since she opened
it in her trailer jennifer was reported
to have spent weeks trying to get them
all out
won't be replicated very easily
jennifer's other co-star liam hemsworth
has also said that working on set was an
absolute blast to the point where it
didn't feel like work
but of course the two being best friends
offset found it awkward to muster up
that
intimate energy for an on-screen kiss in
an interview
the actor revealed that the most awkward
scenes to shoot on set
or any kissing scenes with his co-star
anytime i had to kiss jennifer was
pretty uncomfortable
but don't get it twisted it had nothing
to do with the fact that they weren't
professionals
rather it was because jennifer would
choose specifically what she would eat
for lunch
right before they locked lips she'd be
like yeah i had tuna i had garlic and i
didn't brush my teeth
outside of the katniss peta and gale
love triangle jennifer
also had great relationships with the
other actors on set
one of our favorite on and off screen
dynamics is between jen and the youngest
actor on set
amanda stenberg who played roo jennifer
was really she was great to work with
their chemistry on screen was absolutely
electric and from these outtakes we can
see why
channeling her big sister energy to the
youngest actor on the set makes us feel
all warm and tingly inside their stuff
who wouldn't be busy
fans will not forget the epic and
unforgettable scene in which katniss is
having her last conversation with roo
after she died protecting the tribute
from district 13.
and while this scene had audiences
everywhere tearing up this tribute says
that apparently
jen had this crazy habit of telling
hilarious and inappropriate jokes right
before the director yells action
hey remind me to tell you this really
funny fart truck when this is over
action
oh my god although she may look innocent
and harmless amanda was amongst the most
deviant pranksters on the set of the
first hunger games film
alongside another tribute jacqueline
emerson also known as fox face
madeline jackie those two are like the
dynamic duo
of pranks okay this dynamic duo even
left a signature on a posted note
every time they pulled off a prank their
signature prank was stealing the other
actors clothes or even putting them
in the refrigerator like a note on my on
my mirror that's like
wear your pants jack you'll never find
them probably the most epic prank pulled
off by these young actresses involved
high school girls a stalker scare
jack quaid who played marvel in the
first film and alexander ludwig who
played cato
because the tributes were shooting off
location they all bunked up in a hotel
close by
so naturally amanda and jaclyn pulled
off some major pranks on their fellow
actors
because that's what you do when you're
hanging out with all of your friends
this prank got so intense that
apparently jack really thought he had a
group of fan girl stalkers on his tail
of course once he found out that this
was all staged he knew exactly who was
behind this epic prank
i battled them it was i i i conceded the
war
by now you've probably realized that
although they were out to kill each
other in the first flick the actors who
played the tributes in real life
actually liked each other at the end of
every filming day the gang would hang
out have dance parties and even eat
sushi
just check out this clip of the crew
playing ninja between takes on location
singing in the van and just being silly
teens on set
goddamn i'm so hungry elizabeth banks
who plays effie trinket in the films has
by all means the wackiest
and most performative wardrobe on the
hunger games set
and while we thought she would have
loved dressing to the nines throughout
the films
apparently her outfits prevented her
from being candid and letting loose
because of how heavy
and campy they were i'm stuck in this in
this
all day long there's no question that
pan am fashion is
avant-garde to say the least and while
elizabeth banks or effie was used to it
jennifer expressed that it was difficult
for her at times to channel this
feminine part of herself
check out this behind-the-scenes outtake
of jen expressing how she actually had a
nightmare about being in a big dress in
front of a room full of people
i had this dream that i was in this
ridiculous dress in front of hundreds of
people i don't know
and i just spin around like an idiot
we'll never forget that first scene when
all the tributes are in the arena
it's arguably one of the most dramatic
and intense scenes of the whole movie
and with good reason each person needed
to fight each other to the death for a
chance to get some of the best survival
gear in order to get the best chance of
winning the games
while the scene was beautifully
choreographed what we don't see is how
hot it was that day when the actors were
shooting that famous clip
shout out to juliana for making these uh
coats so hot shooting on location is
always tricky business and so to combat
the heat jennifer apparently spent much
of her time between takes with her pants
around her ankles and just having my
pants around my ankles outside i was
like i don't even care anymore
i don't care there's no question that
the hunger games film put amanda on the
map
her role in the first film completely
catapulted her career
you may have recognized her from the big
blockbuster hit the hate u give but that
doesn't mean she has forgotten her roots
and where it all started
in an interview with jimmy fallon on the
tonight show amanda revealed that
jennifer lawrence was a mentor to her on
the set of the hunger games
in many ways aside from mentoring the
young actress
she also very practically taught amanda
how to pee in the woods
devin let's bring him down
the cast of the harry potter franchise
were all perfectly behaved behind the
scenes
i'm an angel i'm an angel okay
maybe not but they did share some sweet
moments on set
as well as some potentially dangerous
ones if you've ever wondered how slugs
taste or
how ginny coped with being trapped in
the chamber of secrets we'll fill you in
are you so determined to embarrass me
ginny waited so long for harry to
finally return her affections but bonnie
wright wanted to wait even longer before
locking lips with daniel radcliffe
apparently they both felt it was strange
to smooch someone they'd grown up with
which made each actor nervous
needless to say they didn't quite get
this in one take
it took quite a few the first year
bonnie estimates that their nerves
caused them to redo this scene
30 times before harry and ginny's first
kiss looked convincing
in the half-blood prince the lesson
bonnie learned from this when it comes
to kissing
or just filming a kiss sometimes you
just have to go for it
we had fun doing it it was we joked
about you know
speaking of awkward on-set kisses tons
of fans were excited to see hermione and
ron
lock lips for the first time or at least
we're willing to put up with it in
exchange for never having to hear
lavender say again but behind the scenes
rupert grint and emma watson were both
dreading it since they considered
themselves siblings at that point
believe me we both want it to be over
equally as much as the other as clever
as hermione emma came up with a plan
she knows that rather than doing 27
takes she knew if she committed really
early
we'd get it she wasn't about to do 30
takes like bonnie and daniel so she
threw herself at rupert right away
once we did it it was it was nice we
know daniel radcliffe can act but can he
dance you might not know what to believe
after seeing this clip of him
and shefali shadri at the u-ball in
harry potter and the goblet of fire
we learned even witches and wizards have
school dances full of drama
apparently it took a little time for
harry and privati to get their moves
right on set
it is just a rehearsal later daniel
claimed to be a fantastic dancer
but because harry's not very good i
thought i should play it is he a really
bad dancer
or a really good actor ron's brothers
fred and george are notorious
troublemakers but rupert was the real
problem on set
sometimes stars couldn't help but giggle
during a scene and
every cast member in the harry potter
franchise is guilty of this but no one
caused as many disruptions as rupert
you shouldn't be laughing at the end
when you find out that dan's gonna
potentially be
killed by safe his laughter distracted
his co-stars
i can see rupert laughing in the mirror
i can see him i can hear him snigger in
my ear
frustrated the crew rupert will start
giggling and
he'll pretend he isn't giggling and
ended up causing the need for a penalty
system for unsanctioned laughter
bonnie was forced to pay up during the
half-blood prince during the scene in
which ginny brings harry a mince pie
because she just couldn't stop giggling
in harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
first year hogwarts students learn how
to fly brooms for the first time
playing hand games might not be quite as
exciting as soaring through the sky on
brooms but it made for some adorable
behind the scenes moments
apparently emma couldn't help but take
playtime seriously
and her cast members noticed a
competitive streak right away
emma slapping hands with tom felton was
so cute we can't believe she was
smacking him in the face
just a few years after this hermione no
it's not worth it but don't let emma
watson fool you
she's a competitive and clever person
but that doesn't mean she can't be bad
once in a while
this star has broken character due to
laughter quite a few times
and was seen using her cell phone while
on set on the bed
with her shoes on everyone knows
electronics don't work at hogwarts emma
as much as we love the movies they can't
incorporate every element from the books
even if we don't like to admit it one of
the things cut from the films was
hermione's oversized front teeth but it
turns out
emma did have some at least for a while
according to sorcerer's stone director
chris columbus emma is actually wearing
false teeth during this scene but he
realized she couldn't keep acting with
them in her mouth
oh are you doing magic let's see then
what's more difficult than trying to get
a big group of kids to cooperate on set
how about trying to keep them in line
when they're flying through the air
that was a real problem thanks to all
those quidditch matches and when we saw
dueling in harry potter and the chamber
of secrets
maybe that's why harry usually sticks to
a simple disarming spell
as you might have guessed based on this
scene we talked about earlier there was
no love lost between hermione and draco
not unless we're talking about germaine
fanfiction but behind the scenes
emma admits she had a huge crush on tom
felton when they were kids
that's right during the first two films
hermione was really smitten with draco
the entire time
some people think emma and tom are
dating in real life but he claims that
when he found out about her crush
i heard it through the grapevine and
then eventually we became
we became good friends poor emma had to
film her scene on the hogwarts express
with fake teeth
while rupert and daniel got to stuff
their mouths with candy
i've got every single flavor well
hopefully not every flavor
george sweared he got a bogey flavored
one month apparently nobody ever told
daniel not to play with his food
get a snake turn it into a win daniel
radcliffe and rupert grint are friends
in real life but on set they had a few
differences
apparently rupert was a little bit shy
and didn't want to be seen
while he was getting his hair and makeup
done rather not be seen like this yeah
meanwhile daniel had no problem wearing
some different clothes during harry
potter and the deathly hallows
wow we're identical ron learned about
the dangers of a broken wand the hard
way
when he ended up cursing himself with a
slug vomiting charm in chamber of
secrets
we know ron didn't have a lot of fun
being cursed but rupert didn't exactly
enjoy it either
for rupert this movie moment was the
most challenging part of the franchise
at that point
he had to put slimy plastic slugs in his
mouth and then
well you know don't worry there was at
least one upside to filming this scene
but it tasted quite nice actually in
order to make the process a little bit
easier the crew made sure to add
flavoring to the slime
so rupert was tasting chocolate fruit
and peppermint
apparently harry potter in the chamber
of secrets was full of challenges for
the cast
and bonnie wright struggled to get
through one of the scenes ginny weasley
has a bigger part
in the second movie but unfortunately
that was because she was being tormented
by
you know who she ended up in the chamber
of secrets laying on a
very cold marble floor according to
bonnie the floor was so freezing that
she couldn't handle laying on it for
long enough to film the scene so in
order to get her through it
the crew hid hot water bottles in her
clothes to keep her warm
as poor ginny grows weaker emma watson
has had
tons of success both within the harry
potter franchise and outside of it but
there was a time when filming harry
potter and the deathly hallows part 2
she actually missed her mark literally
escaping gringotts wasn't easy behind
the scenes either but at least there
wasn't a real dragon
behind the scenes bloopers are one thing
but helena bonham carter did some real
damage to one of her co-stars while
working on harry potter and the order of
the phoenix bellatrix lestrange has a
real mean streak
while helena's harm was entirely
accidental during one scene bellatrix
gets her hands on neville longbottom
and puts him in peril in front of his
friends it turns out actor matthew lewis
was in real danger of her wand
matthew moved while helena was poking
her wand at his ear and the two collided
ouch matthew ended up with a perforated
eardrum and didn't come clean about what
happened for three days
don't worry the pain and hearing loss
was temporary although the jokes kept on
going
helena says she would always shout to
ask matthew if he was all right after
this i don't know that way
why would they change math math is math
watching the animators and voice actors
put the incredibles 2 together
is pretty freaky just like the parr
family the incredibles crew rolled with
the punches to create a knockout movie
from enthusiastic line reading to
state-of-the-art animation techniques
the incredibles 2 used years of
preparation to create a spectacular film
but that doesn't mean there weren't a
few blunders along the way wait a minute
you're saying what believe it or not
the incredibles don't do everything
together as a family
in fact when they were recording their
lines for the incredibles 2
they were alone with their most
formidable foe yet the director
right right right yeah good okay so
director brad bird
isn't that scary he's actually like a
big teddy bear
but the actors definitely had their work
cut out for them trying to get their
lines just right
for one they aren't even given full
scripts when they come in to record
they're only given their lines and some
direction about how each character was
supposed to feel
uh make it like a private whisper to
yourself like
the rest is up to the superhero voice
actors who made solo studio time sound
pretty incredible
there is one perk to being the only
actor in the sound booth the amazing
solo freakouts that are just as
hilarious to us as they are to the voice
actors
just look at sofia bush who brought
enthusiastic superhero void to life
wow wow it must be hard to fangirl over
superheroes when you're the only one in
the recording studio
but sophia makes void sound like she's
surrounded by every one of her super
powered icons
even after doing the lines over and over
and over again
oh yeah okay joining sofia with another
epic freak out is craig t nelson who
voices the one and only mr incredible
remember that scene when bob was trying
to help dash with his dreaded math
homework
well craig looked just as upset about
math when he was in the recording studio
and let's be honest if you decided to
become a superhero
math probably wasn't one of your
strengths anyway math
is math math is math
helen parr is the feminist icon we all
need she saves the world and her family
and still makes it home in time for
dinner
she does this all with so much
flexibility
i'm not all dark and angsty i'm
elastigirl i'm you know
flexible no one can tell elastigirl what
to do well
except for brad bird who was telling
everyone what to do he made sure
holly hunter the incredible voice behind
our fave female superhero
always set her lines with just the right
amount of attitude holly just had to
make sure to pepper a lot of fake
laughter in there to perfectly capture
lastico's level of annoyance
[Music]
but then there are some voice actors
like catherine keener as evelyn dever
who just couldn't seem to make a mistake
look at her crush this line in just one
take
things would have been different that's
it really we could
almost forgive her for also trying to
crush superheroes everywhere
almost actually we almost got to see
evelyn as a superhero instead of a
villain
can you imagine how different the movie
would have been apparently the villain
kept changing throughout development
catherine herself didn't even know about
evelyn's sudden shift to evil
until she was given her lines for the
scene where she forces the mind control
goggles
onto elastigirl that's a pretty rude
awakening to your suddenly evil nature
but catherine rolled with it like
planning to mind control all superheroes
is just part of her day job
while catherine had to experience
evelyn's descent into evil
bob odenkirk had an entirely different
experience as her brother winston
endeavour brad bird said winston was
supposed to be a huge jerk who was
obsessed with his own ego
you know one of those types spectacular
but bob just radiated such genuinely
energy
that he completely transformed the
character into a genuinely nice person
who really loves superheroes i love
superheroes
the powers the costumes the mythic
struggles
we're happy at least one of the devil
siblings wasn't a total fake
the incredibles 2 is packed with action
and super speedy superheroes
but how do they get that superhero
movement just right well
let's just say dash moves a lot more
slowly in the animation process
than he does once he makes it to the big
screen this behind the scene footage
gave us a quick look at how animators
make dash move so quickly
and it involves hours and hours of
sketching think you'd have the patience
to help animate the next incredibles
movie
speaking of animation the incredibles
crew worked hard to bring fan favorite
character to life for the sequel
but she never actually made it in the
final cut brad bird originally wanted
frozone's wife honey
to be animated this time around and they
went so far as to come up with a
character design and draw a whole scene
of her entrance
ultimately they decided she's funnier as
just a voice
leading us to wonder if she'll ever show
up in an incredibles movie
let us know in the comments if you're
ready for honey to finally have our big
break
here's an insane fact for you the
incredibles 2 had a whole team of people
whose job it is to go into every single
shot of the movie
and make sure that the hair is reacting
and moving correctly yep
the hair the pixar hair program was
entirely changed for this movie
the last time they worked on it it was
for monsters inc with their new program
they were able to create longer more
versatile hair that's pretty realistic
they used this technology to make
violet's hair longer this time around
so she could hide behind it more
effectively when she was feeling shy
you had to have wondered why boyd's
character is super extreme
all the time maybe she reminds you of
something like
an excited puppy if you thought that
then you're right on the money because
brad bird actually based her off of his
dog
who has two moods i love you and i'm
sorry
but void's enthusiastic nervous hand
movements are all sophia bush
if you look at her reading her lines
alongside the animation it looks like
sophia is acting just as much as voicing
the excited superhero
i feel like brad's
dog isn't the only part he put in the
film he actually both created and voices
fan favorite character
edna mode this probably isn't the face
you imagine behind edna but brad does an
incredible job of bringing edna's
attitude to the big screen darling
she's his pride and joy character after
all
the voice acting process may have been
lonely but the collaboration really
shown in the art and animation
department
with all the pieces involved it's no
wonder the sequel took 14 years to make
behind the scene footage gave us an
inside look at how all different
departments get together
and discuss things they love and hate
about the film so that it can be edited
down to perfection
before it hits the big screen brad's
there of course since it's his movie
but he also sits back and lets his team
give their honest opinions
so are these the real superheroes behind
the incredibles it definitely seems like
it
did you know the incredibles actually
takes place in the 60s
the movie seems high-tech and modern but
its 60s retro mixed with advanced
technology
to match the 60s vibes all characters
had retro style icons on which their
fashion and hairstyles were based
helen's style is based on marilyn tyler
moore marilyn monroe
and audrey hepburn while bob's style is
based on paul newman
did you spot any fashion moments in the
incredibles 2 that were definitely based
on the 60s
feel free to share them with us in the
comments for the incredibles 2
they didn't skimp on an epic orchestra
they played live and together to record
all the music
and it's incredible to see them in
action just look at how many people it
takes to make the magic and drama of a
superhero movie come to life
these soundtrack heroes deserve a round
of applause for keeping us on the edge
of our seats
that's really cool yeah
finally let's talk about how voice
actors and animators work together the
line reading comes first
and then as brad explains the animators
listen to the recordings over and over
again until they make the personality of
the voices shine
through the animated characters they
animate and reanimate until it's a
perfect fit
and sometimes they have to even change
things last minute and record new lines
but they figured out seamless ways of
making these changes happen as quickly
as possible
dash might be the one with super speed
but these animators race to the clock
every day to bring our favorite
superhero family to life
it's like a freaking student film
we might not be able to grant you three
wishes like the genie but we're pretty
sure this video is about to make all
your dreams come true
can you make me a princess welcome back
the things fans
it's time for you to get ready to head
into a whole new world
disney has the super important job of
making sure their live-action remakes
come with just as much 90s nostalgia as
their animated versions
and when it comes to the aladdin remake
we can see just how hard they work to
make it perfect by taking a peek behind
the curtain
but they couldn't do it without having
all the fun of course in this video
we're taking you behind the cameras with
bloopers deleted scenes and everything
in between
to show you just how they kept that
nostalgic magic alive
little monkey with the lamp trick this
first deleted scene features acrobat's
finest street rat his pet monkey and of
course the lovely
dahlia we all know the iconic story
about aladdin and jasmine's first
meeting
he saved her after she accidentally
steals from a street merchant to feed
poor children
robin hood is that you but this live
action has been holding back an adorable
love at first sight moment between the
two that never made the final cut
flower petals and all and then they
proceed to quite
literally run for their lives how
romantic
oh dear sorry
speaking of running for their lives what
would an intense disney chase be without
a good musical
number aladdin's performance of one jump
ahead was nothing short of perfect but
that perfection came with a lot of movie
magic
it's just unrealistic to think that a
street cart would be perfectly placed to
carry you to your destination
or that aladdin would make every humanly
impossible jump
well let's just say that a lot of rope
was involved and we're betting a lot of
takes also
shout out to mina masood for absolutely
killing the number though
there are stairs you know where's the
fun in that
with two main characters played by
actors like mina and naomi scott
there's no doubt they had a blast
filming together their chemistry was
iconic both on and off camera and these
adorable behind the scenes moments of
the two will make your heart skip a beat
convince us that they're not literally
aladdin and jasmine in real life
not to mention the adorable pictures the
two of them shared while filming on set
do you have a favorite moment between
these two co-stars
get awful although there was plenty of
skepticism before the live action was
released over whether or not will smith
could pull off being the genie
it's safe to say his character ended up
being a huge hit
how could we doubt that the fresh prince
wouldn't step into that role with
everything he had
while he was in a lot of the movie they
couldn't fit all of his appearances into
the 90 minutes
that's what deleted scenes are for and
this one happens right after aladdin
made a fool of himself when offering
gifts to princess jasmine who doesn't
love fireworks
fireworks i like fireworks
if you've watched aladdin you know that
while the idea of three wishes from a
magical genie sounds pretty ideal they
can have terrible consequences
which is why the genie makes sure
aladdin knows exactly how to make a
proper wish before he touches the lamp
but in this deleted scene the genie
takes his warning a step further and
even tells aladdin's stories of his past
masters
course haid wish to be irresistible to
all women
if you've watched will smith in action
you know that he can't go 10 minutes
without making an entire room burst into
laughter
oh the genie is on fire
so there's no doubt being on set with
this world-renowned celebrity was
anything short of
absolutely hilarious and these behind
the scenes moments with will
are all the proof we need how did they
even get through filming a serious scene
with him
it's a big snake it's a scary snake
a lot of us grew up watching disney
hoping one day to live out our own fairy
tales
true love magic and royalty were what we
dreamed of and the a whole new world
scene was
literally the definition of everything
disney imagine
being whisked away on a magic carpet but
while we'd all love to pretend that that
could actually happen
we're here to burst your bubble and to
show you just how unmagical the filming
for the live action version
actually was well at least we got
adorable behind the scenes moments of
mina and naomi vlogging together
hey hey girl look how beautiful she
looks
we definitely wouldn't have had the
bantering relationship between aladdin
and the genie on screen if there wasn't
a huge bromance off screen
yep we're talking about mina and will if
you thought mina and naomi were adorable
off screen
wait until you see some of the
behind-the-scenes antics these two
actors got into
nina might claim that he's so hard to
work with this is ridiculous but we'd
wager it's actually the exact opposite
what do you guys think of a full-length
movie just of their bloopers
we need it asap he's been amazing i mean
seriously the best
cast mate i could ask for speaking of
off-camera mina well
he's hilarious will definitely wasn't
the only comedian on set during their
months of filming
whether it was throwing out random peace
signs modeling aladdin's outfit
or ruining takes by walking through them
when he wasn't supposed to
he looks like he would be fun to work
with what actor out of the cast would
you want to work with the most
this is max red he's about to get he's
about to get mad at me
this next scene we're going to talk
about took a lot of work not just from
the main cast but from literally
hundreds of people
it's probably the most showy scene of
the movie and if you take a look at the
behind the scenes of it it definitely
wasn't easy to create
it's the genies parade into the castle
singing prince ali
fabulousy alia babwa of course the cgi
team also had a lot of work to
do take a look it's just as much a
pleasure
for me your highness sir sometimes when
you're on set
things just don't go as planned and that
applies to everyone and everything
if every take of a movie went perfectly
it wouldn't take months of filming to
get the film done
whether it's props not cooperating or
actors just having a human moment
we can't all be ninjas in real life
mistakes happen but that doesn't mean
those mistakes can't be hilarious
in fact the aladdin live action has some
pretty hilarious bloopers
let's just say they really know how to
make you fall for them
um oh here
of course jasmine couldn't just return
to the palace grounds and pretend that
nothing had happened during her
rendezvous in agrabah
in this deleted scene the princess
pleads with her father to see what she
does when it comes to their people and
maybe get rid of jafar once and for all
she's a strong independent princess with
an actual pet tiger
and no one not even a villain is going
to stop her it may have taken a while
for him to come around
but she got her way in the end the
people were threatened by your soldiers
not by criminals speaking of jafar this
deleted scene really brings out his true
character
if you weren't sure how far jafar would
actually go to one day rule agrabah
this scene will sure tell you he'll go
to any lengths in order to get his hands
on the genie lamp and his sidekick iago
is right there on his shoulder ready to
help him
every step of the way even if it means
turning to the sands of time
i need real power i need the land
speaking of iago pets are a huge part of
aladdin we have iago abu
and raja as main characters throughout
the film and while this may be a
live-action version of the film
we hate to break it to you but the
animals are still very much cgi
which means during filming they're not
actually next to the actors
well things can get a bit awkward on set
when there's a monologue and the actors
find themselves speaking to a stuffed
animal instead
russia ah prince anders
if only you'd come to woo the princess
before she met aladdin we're sure if his
goofiness hadn't impressed her
his cannon in this deleted scene might
have bombs away
he may not have impressed jasmine but he
sure did impress the studio
disney recently announced that they have
a prince anders spin-off currently at
the work
we can't wait to see where this spin-off
takes him and his canon
how do you feel about disney's
announcement you
naughty girls you lied of course
at the end of the day a movie is only as
good as its cast and this behind the
scenes moment of will
wrapping on set shows you just how much
love was between both the cast and crew
we can't be anything but grateful that
disney managed to put together such an
amazing team to bring us some more
disney magic we're sweating just
thinking about how much time and effort
went into making this film disney ready
kudos to mina naomi and will for pulling
off some of the biggest disney
characters ever while still managing to
keep the fun behind the scenes alive
what was your favorite behind the scenes
moment do you think they should have
kept in any deleted scenes
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up
hit that subscribe button and we'll see
you next time
you